gas prices hitting historic new highs on
tuesday in the united states up 17 cents
in just the last week to hit a record
four dollars and 37 cents a gallon u.s
consumers are unhappy i don't even look
at how many gallons anymore or what
their dollar amount is anymore because
it's expensive everywhere everywhere
it's another blow to the u.s economy and
president joe biden's white house i
heard the first first-hand term working
for and i said that's us
we're working we're working our full
time and we're still having a hard time
maintaining managing being able to buy
groceries gas under pressure to help
consumers biden on tuesday insisted his
policies are fighting inflation
i know you've got to be frustrated
frustrated by high prices by gridlock in
congress
by the time it takes to get anything
done
believe me
i understand the frustration
he blamed rising prices on the global
pandemic and on the war in ukraine but
he also attacked republicans for pushing
an ultra mega agenda referring to former
president donald trump's make america
great again policies he believes do not
align with mainstream american values
the republican plan is an increased
taxes on the middle class families led
billionaires and large companies off the
hook
as they raise profits raise prices and
re-profits of record number
record amounts
and it's really that simple biden
insists if republicans are elected to
control congress in november's midterm
elections they'll end social spending
that millions rely on like medical care
for the poor and elderly
biden once insisted high prices supply
chain shortages and record high
inflation on basics like food and rent
was temporary but that's no longer the
case inflation has more than wiped out
the average workers wage gains
president biden
has handed the average american
a big pay cut
a pay cut polls show on the issue of the
economy more americans trust republicans
policies than president bidens with
approval ratings in the low 40 percent
and with congressional midterm elections
just months away
record high inflation has become a
political liability for the president
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house